Over the past month or so,
I think many people have been concerned about
the war between the U.S., Israel, and Iran —
a conflict that has shaken the global situation.
Today I'd like to start with this topic,
but from a different angle.
I think war serves as a kind of stage —
one where you can see how astonishing human invention can be.
In this war,
you can see all kinds of different weapons.
I don't know if you've been following the news,
but in the upper-left corner here,
that's the MOAB — the Mother of All Bombs.
It's the most powerful bomb in the conventional arsenal.
Even just to drop it,
they need a C-130 Hercules transport plane,
because it's too heavy and too large.
This Mother of All Bombs
is the strongest in the conventional category.
If you want to go beyond that,
you have to step into unconventional weapons —
nuclear weapons, for example.
So this one is really pushing the limit.
Next to it is the bunker-buster bomb.
As you know, Iran has many
underground missile cities,
underground nuclear facilities.
The bomber that drops these bunker busters is the B-2.
The picture at the bottom left
is a torpedo —
a Mk 48 heavyweight torpedo.
You might still remember, in the Indian Ocean,
an Iranian frigate
that had finished joint exercises with India
was returning to Iran
when it was sunk en route by a U.S. submarine.
Honestly, that frigate wasn't a major warship,
and it wasn't particularly advanced.
A missile would have been enough to take it out.
With a missile,
you'd at least give the crew a chance to escape.
But they actually used this heavy torpedo.
If you watch the footage on YouTube,
you'll see the ship went down very fast.
Sri Lanka —
by the time Sri Lanka's old vessels arrived,
the ship had already sunk.
Why use a heavyweight torpedo against it?
The story is that on board the U.S. submarine that day —
a Los Angeles-class sub —
there were two Australian naval officers undergoing training.
You know, Australia bought nuclear submarines from the U.S.,
and in doing so,
in a way they tacitly agreed
that if anything happens at the first island chain in the Pacific,
Australia would join the fight.
So inside that submarine that day,
it was effectively combat training as well.
And next to it,
another impressive one.
That one is called the graphite bomb.
They threatened —
to bomb Iran's power plant with it.
But notice — it's not the kind of weapon that harms civilians.
Because they noticed one phenomenon:
in some rural areas, in places with very few people,
the electricity consumption was surprisingly high.
That usually means there are nuclear facilities behind it,
or maybe military installations.
So the U.S. demand —
their threat to bomb the power plant —
but if you actually destroyed the plant, that would be terrible:
it would affect many people and civilian life.
So what is this graphite bomb?
The moment it's deployed,
the graphite itself causes massive short-circuits,
which knocks out power transmission.
But the power plant itself
and the generating equipment are not destroyed.
You can see — isn't that remarkable?
Actually these kinds of warfare technologies —
take U.S. drones, for example.
The Lucas drone.
Then there are unmanned speedboats, unmanned vessels.
In the lower-left corner you can see one called Starshield.
That's also from SpaceX.
Starlink is for civilian use.
Starshield is for military use.
So if you take apart the nose cone of these drones,
you'll find there are receivers inside,
and those tap into Starshield for navigation.
And in the upper-right corner,
that one is a laser cannon.
Actually, since around 2023,
one thing that's become very popular
is the so-called saturation attack.